- They put the
protestors in buses.
It started off with
400, then it was 1200.
The last number I heard
was that they captured
about 1700 people
and they bring them
to the federal police
training facility in Brasilia,
stick 'em in the gymnasium. No
food, no water, no bathrooms.
Young kids, no food.
Old women, dehydrated.
Intel says, and it's been
pretty well verified,
that at least one
person's died that day.
I heard two people.
Now they say it's
up to four or five.
And they basically
create a gulag,
which are being called in
Brazil Lulacs: Lula gulags.
- Yeah.
- A portmanteau.
And now, after two days of that,
that was Monday and Tuesday,
they let the women
and children go...
By the way, the
images of old people
sitting in puddles
of their own urine
because there's no bathrooms,
sweltering conditions,
no food, no water.
They let the older women and
the women and children go
on the condition, and we
have these floating around,
a denunciation page.
You have to sign it
to be released saying,
"I am a terrorist. I
assaulted democracy."
And this now has them on lists.
They will never get a job again.
(upbeat intro music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is a journalist,
an author, and a Lincoln Fellow
at the Claremont
Institute, Matthew Tyrmand.
Matthew, finally welcome to
The Rubin Report. How are you?
- It's an honor to
be with you, Dave.
You forgot the most
important honorific: friend.
- And friend.
You are one of the people in
our little Florida crew here,
our little Florida Freedom crew.
Basically, this is home base
for sanity throughout the world.
I've wanted to have you
on for quite some time,
because, you know, there's
this whole thing...
Well, I know you know this.
There is this whole
situation, let's say,
happening in Brazil,
which has been unfolding
after these elections for
the last couple months.
I've only talked about it
maybe two or three
times on the show.
It is not my area of expertise,
but the crazier it
seems to get out there
with the visuals of the
protestors and everything else,
it seems to me the more the
mainstream media is ignoring it
and that's one of the things
that always lights
up in my mind, like,
"Oh, mainstream
media's ignoring it.
We better pay attention to it."
You basically have
been, I don't know,
possibly the most
outspoken person
from an American perspective
on what's going on in Brazil.
So let's do this.
Can you give me 30 seconds
on your background,
why people should trust
you on this topic?
And then let's do
a little Brazil 101
and then get people
caught up to speed
on what's going on
over there right now.
- Sure.
As I said, great to be with you
and you know, thank
you from, you know,
on my behalf as well
as Brazilian's behalf,
because they feel
very, very ignored
and I've become
somewhat of their voice,
sort of for the Western press
from a right wing perspective,
a Conservative perspective,
an honest perspective as
they've been totally...
Their voice has been negated
as their laws have
been abrogated.
You know, I didn't expect
Brazil to be my beat.
I'm an investigative journalist
and a political activist.
I wear my politics on my
sleeve; everybody knows it.
This is not, you know, my
vocation professionally,
I do not make money
as an activist
or in campaigns
or in journalism,
I do it because of
the love of the game
and the belief in
truth to power.
You know, we have mutual
friends like James O'Keefe,
I'm on the board
of Project Veritas,
I help manage a group in Chicago
called Open the Books that
does forensic auditing
in the public sector,
all things I believe are
important to, you know,
make a more honest society
because our society is as
broken as it's ever been.
I did not expect
Brazil to be my beat.
I've been covering a lot of
international geopolitics
from a European perspective.
I'm a Polish dual citizen.
I live in Europe, a
good chunk of the time.
I've certainly covered
Russia-Ukraine,
especially from the
Polish perspective,
given that they're sort
of in the line of fire.
But, you know, I cover the
Sovereigntist movements
in Europe, Westphalian
sovereignty as
expressed in politics,
whether it's Poland or Hungary
or the right wing parties
in Sweden and Spain and
France and Germany, et cetera.
I didn't expect to do
Brazil, but here we are.
I went there for CPAC in
'21 with Jason Miller,
gave a speech about exactly
this, honest media, free press,
culture war and lo and behold,
as we were exiting the country,
we were detained by Alexandre
Moraes, the Supreme Court,
which we will speak
about, and interrogated
and asked to write down the
names of who we met with,
the politicians, the
activists, the journalists
and it had a very Stalinesque
feel to it, you know?
"Give us the next tranche
of our enemies list."
Of course, we did
not comply with that
and from that, I, you know,
germinated an interest.
I wanted to understand
exactly what-
- Wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
I gotta pause you there. You're
trying to leave a country...
- Yes.
- They ask you for the
list, they detain you,
you don't comply...
- Yes.
- That's not an
easy thing to do.
I think you glossed
over how that ended.
- Well, they said we
were not under arrest.
We were part of what they call
The Fake News Investigation,
and we'll talk about this.
For years, the court and the
burgeoning judicial autocracy
had put every one of the
political enemies of the court,
of the Lula camp into this box
of by being critical of the
court or any of the things
in government that was not
aligned with Bolsonaro,
they were assaulting
democratic institutions.
That's the sort of
framework that they applied.
And so they've had this
Fake News Investigation
that has given them the
pretext to censor journalists,
arrest journalists, even
arrest sitting members
of the Lower House in Brazil.
They put Daniel Silveira
under house arrest.
A lot of ankle bracelets
rolling around there.
And so I knew that
going in to some degree.
I got educated
more on the ground.
Jason Miller and I, and
if people don't know,
this is Trump's sort of
campaign main comms guy,
very, very close to Trump,
very, very high profile
figure in his own right.
And he was building out
GETTR at the time, still is,
an alternative to
Twitter that, you know,
is more egalitarian,
freedom oriented,
especially as Twitter was
a highly censored platform,
as we all know, as
I know you know.
And so he was going to
talk about that at CPAC
and promote it and I was
talking about, you know,
Project Veritas and media.
And I organized... Because
I am quite friendly
over the years with
Eduardo Bolsonaro
and other members of
the Bolsonaro family,
I organized a meeting with
all of us and Jair Bolsonaro,
the sitting president
at the palace
and those pictures that
we posted went viral.
And it turned out
that on the Sunday...
We were leaving on a Monday.
On the Sunday after
CPAC had concluded,
news stories broke in
the stenographer press,
the guild carrying
mainstream press of Brazil,
which actually makes CNN
here look downright honest.
(Dave laughing)
I mean, these guys
were really...
- Wow, wow.
- ... really Pravda,
really propagandist.
Incidentally, not
surprisingly, they were also
on the payroll of the previous
regimes quite heavily.
State-owned enterprises were
funding much of their revenue,
advertising and whatever else.
So they reported on
the Sunday afternoon
before we were supposed to leave
that we'd been under
surveillance from
the moment we landed.
And I told Jason, you know,
I spent a lot of time in
Central and Eastern Europe,
post-communist nations.
I've been tapped, I've been
surveilled, I've been watched,
I've been dragged into, you
know, kangaroo court hearings.
None of this stuff surprises me.
And I told him, and I said,
"You know, there's a good chance
we're gonna be detained
at the airport."
And he goes, "No,
you're being paranoid."
"I'm not being paranoid. I
think it'd be kind of great.
It would serve the
point quite perfectly."
I also have dual citizenship,
which is kind of helpful.
And we were.
So we were leaving
on Monday to fly out
and before we can get to our
plane, they say, you know,
"Please come with us."
We had a traveling party
of four, Jason, myself,
and two dual Brazilian
American citizens
that came with us and also
had been involved with CPAC
and they really...
Jason was the main one
they wanted to talk to,
and so they let us sit on
the plane for a little bit.
And three, four hours goes by,
lawyers are called, State
Department lawyers called,
they say, "Well, you're
screwed. Get another lawyer."
So they weren't very helpful.
Eventually, Jason was able
to procure a good lawyer
through Brazilian contacts to
come and help extricate us.
But it became a big story.
When we were flying out
Politico, CNN, Forbes,
Business Insider,
they all picked it up
about our detention.
But it was very,
very instructive
of how heavy handed they are.
Here we are, you
know, not Brazilians,
just coming in in a
constitutional republic,
we can come and
speak our ideas...
Well, or so we thought.
Apparently not without
some sort of repercussion.
And they wanted to probe and
understand who we met with
to add to their enemies list.
So from that moment
on, I just said,
"I'm gonna go deep. I'm
gonna talk to people.
I'm gonna really understand
the history, how we got here,
the mechanisms of
power that are in place
and being utilized to
clamp down on opposition."
And I learned a lot in
the following months
and I published on it
ahead of the election
and I basically predicted
that this election
would be filled with, you
know, to use a generous term,
anomalies, but this...
Even Tucker said it the
other night when I was on,
the fix was in. The
fix was in, you know?
The real genesis
of the fix being in
was this court subsuming
all these powers
that are generally broken down
in a constitutional republic.
They're very Bismarckian.
Remember Otto Von Bismarck said,
"Politics is the art
of the possible."
They just do it.
And the power
assumptions they've done
by censoring journalists,
by shaping the narrative,
by forcing people and
cowing them into submission
is overwhelming.
You know, I wrote in
one of my articles,
"The powers they've taken
would make Mugabe blush."
It would be akin to in the
U.S. if we had one tribunal
that had all the powers of
the DOJ, say Merrick Garland,
the head of the FBI
enforcement, subpoena power,
the Legislator's
power of oversight.
So say, you know, Jerrold Nadler
and the recent select committee
or unselect committee.
All of these powers were...
Oh and the Supreme Court
of course, you know?
Like Ruth Bader Ginsburg also.
So if you wrapped up all
these people, Eric Holder,
everyone who is fighting,
you know, the American right
and you gave one
body and one person
all of their powers combined,
that's what the Supreme
Court has become.
And as a result, it's up
for quite gross abuse.
One of their biggest
gross abuses was they...
- Wait, hold on.
Let me pause you for a sec
'cause there's a lot here,
I wanna make sure we don't
get ahead of ourselves.
First off, everything that
you just described there,
I feel like is
basically slow motion
happening in this country.
I mean, in this country
that we're in right now;
that's one problem.
But okay, so there was a
centralization of power.
This is last year first,
when you got detained.
Now you're deep into this thing,
you're predicting sort
of what's gonna happen
with the election and I
don't wanna get too...
Just because I'm trying to
intro everybody to this,
I don't wanna get too lost
in all of the weeds of this.
- [Matthew] Sure.
- So let's just flash a little
bit towards the election.
So it's a couple days
before the election,
what were you thinking
was gonna happen?
And can you just describe the
two candidates a little bit?
Because it really is...
In essence, this is a capitalist
versus socialist fight
that's happening there.
- Yeah. And very, very basic...
I mean, hard right,
hard left, you know?
The Brazilian right is
more and more evangelical.
Brazil's always been Catholic.
Brazil's populism that Bolsonaro
really became the head of,
and he was a legislator
before his career in military,
than he was a legislator
in the Lower House,
a congressman, they call
it the Chamber of Deputies.
The populism that he
came in with to Brazil
was really reactionary.
Obviously, we saw what's
going on in the whole world.
Poland and Hungary reacting
against the EU overreach
of their sovereign decision
making capacity on borders,
on economics, on everything.
Trump, Brexit...
So Bolsonaro comes in in 2018
and he obviously
is a Conservative,
he's a right-winger, very,
very strongly aligned
with Evangelicals, with Israel,
very much a believer
in Brazil first
and also a guy warning about
China's deep integration
into the evermore
communist Latin America.
And the important history
is why Bolsonaro's reaction
because before Bolsonaro,
you had Lula da Silva,
Dilma Rousseff and Michel Temer.
Lula was a two-term president
who was impeached, convicted
and sent to jail for
a very, very famous...
Made one of the largest
public corruption scandals
in the history of the world.
It's called Operation Car Wash.
You could even...
It's so brazen and overdone
that even the Wikipedia is
accurate because you can't-
- (laughs) Wow, that's a-
- You can't spend billions
of dollars stolen...
They call it Lava
Jato in Brazil.
And they were selling
under Lula's presidency,
essentially the state assets,
natural resource assets,
state assets for cash in bags
to the Chinese, to others,
taking nice commissions
for themselves.
Huge money was changing
hands within their cabal.
And also very importantly,
sending money to
Cuba via Petrobras.
Petrobras is the
state oil company,
one of the biggest in the world
and they were helping support
Cuba by giving them free oil,
even though it's a
joint stock company
with international investors,
so very, very,
very illegal stuff.
He was convicted of a
dozen charges by 19 judges
in three separate hearings;
three separate court trials.
So when they say, "Oh, well
it was fixed, it was wrong."
No, no. Three separate
tribunals of 19 judges
unanimously convicted
him of 12 charges
and sentenced him
to 12 years in jail.
His judicial appointees,
him and Dilma,
people from his own party,
they appointed these judges,
Supreme Court and other courts,
they let him out citing a
jurisdictional technicality.
Now that is an absolute canard
because he stole from
the entire country.
So in the jurisprudence
along the Brazilian
constitutional lines,
there are no jurisdictions
where he would not
be eligible for trial
because he stole from everybody.
These judges that
unanimously found him guilty,
these were not Bolsonaro people.
These people predated
Bolsonaro by many years.
And in fact, even
the mainstream media
at the time was covering it.
Even the military, when we talk
about the Brazilian military
in the mixed bag of their
political allegiances,
they were defending
the protestors
on the street when this broke.
So he goes to jail.
Dilma Rousseff, his
vice president in
essence, takes over.
She ends up impeached and
convicted for the same thing.
She gets kicked out of office.
Her vice president,
Michel Temer comes in
and only serves out two years.
Very, very pro-China.
When he left, he had 7%
approval, which is, you know,
pretty historic lows for
any constitutional republic
to have 7% approval
of a head of state.
Bolsonaro got elected
on a wave of this,
just discontent, distrust in
the corruption of this cabal.
Lula politically is, you know,
I read sometimes
in mainstream press
now that they are covering it
because it's expedient to do
so to further their narrative,
he's a socialist.
He's not a socialist,
he's a communist.
He is a full on Marxist,
hammer and sickles,
five pointed stars.
In 1990, he co-founded
the Sao Paolo Forum with,
drum roll please, Fidel Castro.
And the genesis of this was,
the Soviet Union was breaking
down between '89 and '91.
The Soviet Union for the
better part of 50 or 60 years
was feeding money to
Cuba and using Cuba
as the base of operations
for this hemisphere
to incubate and inculcate
Marxist political movements
all over Latin America.
So with the Soviet Union,
that well running dry,
Lula and Fidel realized
they needed to do it
and you couldn't do
it out of Cuba per se
because of all the sanctions.
So Lula created in Brazil
the Sao Paolo Forum
as an incubating vehicle,
like a think tank,
like an AEI on the
right or a Brookings
or a World Economic
Forum to push the ideas
and to teach the
political players.
And they were very much behind
the rise of Chavismo,
Chavez, Maduro.
There is no Latin
American communist
that did not go through
Forum Sao Paolo trainings.
Ortega in Nicaragua,
Morales in Bolivia,
Arce who's now in Bolivia,
Maduro and Chavez,
Kirchner, Fernandez and
more recently in Columbia,
which was sort of a righty
country because of the reaction
against the Marxist gorilla
narco trafficantes of FARC,
you now have a
leader named Petro
who also was a Marxist gorilla
with another sort of drug
moving gorilla force.
He's now head under some
questionable election...
Runnings of the election.
And then in Chile,
another country
that sort of bounced between
right and center left,
was never a hard left
Bolivia or Venezuela,
now you've got Boric, another
student Marxist leader
that was incubated by
the Sao Paolo Forum.
Brazil is the gold standard.
Brazil is what they needed
to bring it all together.
So the judges released him,
made him a sort of figurehead.
He couldn't go...
I mean, this sounds familiar,
he couldn't go out and
campaign, much like Biden.
But you know, when
Biden couldn't campaign,
it was because there
was no enthusiasm.
When Lula couldn't campaign,
it's because if he
went into public
and walked down the street,
he'd be ripped limb
from limb like Gaddafi.
He's not liked. Everybody
in the country...
I even was on Twitter
spaces the other day
and I even got the communists
who were on these spaces
in this debate to concede,
"Oh yeah, of course he was
guilty of public corruption.
Everybody knows that."
Which I start tweeting at them
that they admitted that
for their base. So-
- All right, so wait.
Let's pause for a second.
Okay, so there's a lot here,
so I wanna make sure
everyone's following all this.
So you have the communist that
was in charge for a while,
there's all this corruption,
he's basically selling
the country off to China
piece by piece.
Eventually he gets
released, starts this forum.
You've explained how this
sort of got exported...
- The Forum was in 1990.
- Yeah, so-
- This is where he
built his political...
- So now this is sort of
exported all through the region.
Now let's get...
Then Balnasaro takes over,
he has a couple pretty
good years actually,
but then we have this election.
So get us caught
up really starting
a little bit before the election
'cause I want
people to understand
really what some of the...
Because we're gonna show some
B-roll as you're talking-
- [Matthew] Good.
- ... of the protest
and everything post-election.
- [Matthew] Good.
- But I want people
to understand
why there are these
people out there,
what they are doing
and how our media
is trying to really, really
paint them in this, you know,
"These are the ultra
MAGA Republicans
that are out there
doing all this stuff."
- Yeah. No, this is a
silent majority center.
I mean these are not, you
know, Oath Keepers, Proud Boys
as much as they like to spin it.
So very, very important is
that Bolsonaro comes in in '18
and very, very quickly,
the rallies around him
are driven toward the
debate over elections
because people know...
Nobody expect... Much like
Hillary Clinton and Trump,
they didn't expect
Bolsonaro to win.
The leftist establishment,
the courts, the media,
they thought they would be fine.
Bolsonaro actually won and I
really believe that it was,
you know, this sort
of circumstance...
He got stabbed while
on the campaign trail
and he was almost
assassinated, almost murdered
and the strength he showed
inspired a lot of people.
He was back on the...
I mean, he was near death.
He was in the ICU and then
he's back on the campaign trail
and he eeks in the victory
and of course now
they're apoplectic.
Now they have to go
especially aggressive,
the establishment, and
how do we undermine him
and how do we make sure
this doesn't happen again?
Very, very important data
point, when he was in Congress,
he sponsored a bill
that was passed
to have backup paper ballots
to the electronic
voting machines,
which they started using a
certain Venezuelan company
in 2016 and people kind of knew,
"We don't trust Latin
American democracies
because we're..."
This is not like, you know, us
thinking back 100 years ago,
this is for them
20, 30 years ago
what Latin America looked
like: military dictatorships,
heavily Marxist rule in
many of the countries,
it kind of bounces
back and forth.
And so people knew
that, you know,
they're always one step
away from going back to that
and so massive
rallies in the street.
"Give us paper..."
I was there in Brasilia
when I saw a rally
and the chants are,
"Give us paper ballots."
That is what they want.
So he pushes a bill
in '16, you know,
for backup paper ballots.
Dilma was president at the time.
She vetoes it citing,
you'll love this, the cost.
So the machines themselves
are 20,000 bucks,
a printer's $100 bucks.
(Dave laughs)
And she cites, "Well this
is fiscally irresponsible
to put a printer in the..."
and everybody knew that was
a BS, you know, reasoning.
- Can't you just borrow
the money from China?
- Yeah, well, I mean it's a
de minimis cost right now,
printers, as we know.
(Dave laughs)
It's the beauty of
capitalism, prices go down.
- Yeah.
- So it goes back to Congress.
Congress overrides the
veto. That never happens.
Brazilian congressional
politics, legislative politics,
very fragmented; it's
not like two parties.
There's like 10 parties
and really five frames,
center left, hard left, center,
center right, hard right
and then multiple
parties in each one.
Overwhelming support for this
in the legislature and then...
So it now overrides
her veto, gets passed,
Supreme Court strikes it
down citing privacy issues.
So they were very at
war with paper ballots
because they knew that
that would be auditable.
So now he's, you know, talking
about this as president
and people are obviously
nervous coming in
because they let
Lula out of prison
and they're citing all
the international press,
"Lula's back out
on a technicality,
absolute nonsense."
"Lula's back out
on a technicality,
absolute nonsense."
'Cause the criminality was
so high, everybody knew it.
So now the court is going
full interference mode
in every which way.
Arresting and
censoring journalist.
A great journalist, here in
the U.S., Allan dos Santos.
He's like Brazil's
Tucker Carlson.
I mean, like, if you
could pick one journalist
who represents the
voice of the people
from a Conservative and
right wing perspective...
He's been exiled.
They ransacked his
house and he escaped
and claimed asylum here.
He has a sort of
temporary asylum.
And more recently they've
revoked his passport
and put out Interpol
red notices for him.
This is how heavy
handed they are.
They arrested sitting
members of Congress,
dozens of journalists.
As I mentioned before, a
lot of ankle bracelets,
a lot of home detentions,
frozen bank accounts,
deplatforming.
They started going
after big tech
and saying, "Anytime we send
you somebody to deplatform,
you have to take them
off or we will fine you.
If you ignore the fines,
we will come after you,
we will kick you
out of the country."
And even Facebook initially
and YouTube pushed back,
we're talking like
four years ago or so.
They said, "No, we
don't see grounds
for a social media suspension
or a blacklist or a ban."
And they said, "Well, we
don't care if you see grounds,
if you don't do it, we're
gonna raid your servers
and kick you out
of the country."
And by the way,
this Supreme Court
has their own
federal police force,
like an FBI that's
loyal to them.
So they have real power, real
muscle behind, you know...
What is the Supreme Court
supposed to do in a
constitutional republic?
Adjudicate legislation if
it's constitutional or not.
They're so far beyond that.
And the guy who runs it wasn't
a judge, he was a prosecutor.
He was a very famous,
zealous political prosecutor
from Sao Paolo that
Temer appointed.
This is a guy, Alexandre Moraes.
For anybody who like
is researching Brazil,
looks at my articles or
anything on social media,
he's the guy who looks like
a Brazilian Lex Luthor.
He looks exactly
like Lex... (laughs)
I mean, a big, shit
eating grin on his face,
drunk with power and
he literally just has
anybody he doesn't
like arrested.
So Bolsonaro tried
to fight back on it,
but he was kind of hamstrung.
The legislature wasn't
overwhelmingly for
Bolsonaro either.
I mean, very fragmented.
So now you have leading
into the election,
all the polls done by
the usual suspects,
the mainstream press, Global
Folha, the equivalent of CNN
are saying that Lula is
up by like 20 points.
He's gonna win in a landslide.
Well, the end of
the first round,
Lula was up by three
or four points.
Neither got over 50% and
really, as I believe I proved
in my CDM Media...
I write for an outlet
called cdm.press.
The publisher's name is
Todd Wood, ex-military,
he's not afraid of anything,
so he'll publish me.
I touch some third rails.
I did some statistical analysis
with an international
group of forensic auditors
and analysts in electoral
distributions, political science
and what we saw in
just the first round,
let alone second round,
was that Bolsonaro
was well up initially
until the ballot drops skewed
after the first 10 or
so percent of precincts.
Every single one
therein was 55, 45 Lula,
including in regions...
I mean, certainly in regions
that were historical
leftist strongholds,
poorer areas in the Amazon,
a lot of indigenous
tribes people
used to vote for Lula,
for Dilma, for the
socialist programs
like Bolsa Família
redistributing wealth.
Well, it turns out
that in those precincts
there were zero
votes for Bolsonaro,
which was so brazen
because many of the...
Bolsonaro did bring a
lot of people together.
People really did
like him on the ground
and they ended up in these
marches and as protest leaders,
the indigenous tribal leaders,
and they have special rights
in the Brazilian constitution.
They don't have...
It's almost like American Indian
Native American reservations.
There's sort of
a dual legal code
and some things apply to
them, some things don't.
And so they were leading the
protest movements as well
and the chief of
the (indistinct)
is still in jail
from January 12th on.
My intel tells me they've
been torturing him,
trying to get him to
sign a self denunciation
and public apology to Moraes.
This is coming from his family
and his fellow tribe members.
So the first round, they're
marching because they're like,
"No, we did vote for Bolsonaro.
There's no way in these
precincts, in our region,
that there were zero votes.
So we know that there
was gross fraud."
In the second round, the
clampdowns came down to...
Because first round, if you
don't win a simple majority...
And there was like six
or seven candidates.
Nobody got over 50%.
So it goes to a runoff
between Bolsonaro and Lula
four weeks after the first
round, Sunday, October 2nd,
and then Sunday, October 30th.
And then the same exact thing
happens in the second round.
Bolsonaro is way up initially,
and then the ballot drops
55, 45 give or take,
until they both cross over,
both the first round
and the second round,
they crossed over to a Lula lead
at 66.66% of precincts reporting
(Dave laughs)
Which is like...
And by the way, if
you're a mathematician,
the standard deviation
sort of differentials
and Fibonacci level...
66.66 is a very important number
in statistics for a reason.
And so it's kind of interesting
with the algorithms,
how it somehow ended up there.
So-
- Okay, again, let me
pause you for a second.
So basically, there's
all this corruption,
he's running on this idea that,
"We have to secure
our elections."
This actually sounds... There's
a reason I wanted to do this
for my audience that mostly
focuses on American politics.
The themes here obviously
are transcending borders.
So then they... Okay,
there's the first one,
there's the second one
and now people are going,
"Something really isn't right"
because what they're
seeing out of the media
is really not matching up
with what they're
seeing on the ground.
Again, this sort
of seems familiar.
- Here's another important point
between the first round
and the second round.
In the first round,
Bolsonaro's party did
unprecedentedly well.
Regions that they never
secured governorships
or senators or Lower
House legislators,
they'd never had that
representation; his party.
On the strength of his
endorsement alone one handily.
- Yeah.
- Unprecedented how much...
19 out of 27... One third
of the Senate seats...
81 Senate seats are up.
One third of them...
And he got 19 out of
that one third, 27.
That is a massive
mandate. Governorships...
Down ballot, everybody
performed well.
And these are not people who
even had political identities.
Their entire identity
was predicated
with the fact Bolsonaro said,
"Okay, go for this guy."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And they won easily.
(chuckles) So again,
everyone's like,
"Something's rotten in
the state of Brazil,"
to paraphrase Hamlet.
They start marching
on the second round.
The day after October 30th,
so October 31st, that Monday,
that was the first...
I'm sure you'll show
some of this footage...
- Yeah, so we'll play some
footage right now just to...
You can keep going and
we're just gonna show you
'cause these we're
extraordinary images.
- We're not talking
tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands; we're
not even talking millions.
We're talking eight figures.
People in the streets, not
just in Brasilia or the major,
you know, cities like Sao Paolo
and Rio or Belo Horizonte,
we're talking leftist
strongholds in the
north like Recife.
Every city in the country,
their town square was filled
with people screaming about
this saying, "No, we..."
And you know, part of it is
they also know communism.
They don't wanna be communists.
They know Lula's an
actual communist.
And so the protests are massive.
And as I was saying on, you
know, a lot of the appearances,
the revolution will
not be televised.
Not a single Reuters dispatch.
BBC, NBC, NPR, nothing, silence.
Globo, their fake news media
decides that they wanna
prove to the world
how there are no protests,
so they go to a back alley
and go, "See? Nobody's here."
(Dave laughs)
That's how gross and Pravda
and Soviet and brazen it is.
The protests accelerate
into the certification.
The certification...
And by the way, very important.
There is the Supreme Court,
which is the, you know,
creme de la creme
of the pyramidical
distribution of judiciary,
but right under the Supreme
Court is the Electoral Court,
the Tribune Superior
Electoral. Guess what they do?
They oversee the elections,
administer the elections.
Guess who's the head of it?
The same Chief Justice
appointed himself
from the Supreme Court,
Alexandre Moraes,
as head of the Electoral Court,
so he's been head of the
Electoral Court as well
and uses that as
anytime somebody leading
into the election
between the first
and the second round,
after the second round says,
"The election might
have been fraudulent."
Electoral Court says,
"You're assaulting the
democratic institution,
you're besmirching the faith
and integrity of our elections.
You're under arrest. Your
bank account's frozen.
You've been deplatformed
on social media."
So gross abuses,
Soviet-style, in power.
Now the military
wakes up and they say,
"Well, the constitution
says in Article 142,
we have the role in
society of when there's
a separation of powers
dispute to adjudicate it
and as we have now, the
judiciary is at odds
with the executive branch
and so it's the military's
job to adjudicate it."
So they file a petition
to audit the machines,
the tabulation date
and the source code,
which is very much their
constitutional right
and responsibility.
The Electoral Court
says, "Pound sand."
They ignore it entirely.
Military puts out a 65 page
audit report that says,
"Well, we can't give
anything conclusive
because they wouldn't let us
near the actual evidence."
Then right after that, you've
got the head of the party,
Bolsonaro's party,
the liberal party, PL
say in front of the court,
"We also found fraud.
We're petitioning the
court to address this."
They say, "This is nonsense.
You are guilty of
fraud by telling us
that we are possibly fraudulent.
We're gonna fine your
party 22 million Reals,"
5, 6 million bucks,
"and now you're under criminal
investigation for fake news
and assaulting
democratic institutions."
So, I mean, we see
a pattern here-
- Yes, there is
something going on.
- The Vice Titans more and more.
Now I said this, you know,
Bolsonaro did not, you know,
prevail in this election,
the trend towards Venezuela
would be very, very quick.
And I am even shocked with my
cynicism how quick it's been.
So now we have, you know,
the military does fail to
act and invoke martial law.
I believe Bolsonaro
was pushing that.
He had some generals behind
him, some not behind him.
In the end, he
leaves, Lula comes in,
and now you have this protest
that was very well telegraphed.
I mean, I was seeing stuff
all over social media,
"We're marching on Brasilia
into three power squares."
Three power squares, the
picture where you have
the sort of sunken
in giant field-
- Yep.
- [Matthew] In between
the three major buildings,
the National Congress,
the Supreme Court,
and the Presidential
Executive Branch Palace,
the Palo Alto... I forget.
Not Palo Alto, that's
where you guys are from.
- [Dave] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Matthew] And they
marched to this.
And now we already have
videos after the fog of war
that show there were
agent provocateurs
already in the National Congress
taking hammers to the windows,
screwing up all the chairs,
ripping stuff off the wall,
waiting for the thongs
of people to enter.
And then, "Hey guys, come
in. The water's nice."
They came in. You have
videos of the protestors...
And by the way, it's almost
like a kind of kumbaya,
like you've never seen such
a cross-section society.
Every race, male and female,
every age, 10-year-old kids,
80-year-old men and
women all together
and then they're arguing
with the agent provocateurs,
"No, don't break that."
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah.
- Don't rip that off the wall.
Don't bang a chair
until the legs fall off.
They're arguing. We have
tons of videos of this.
Then the National Guard,
the federal police come in
and they have a little
bit of a standoff
with the military police
who are generally
defending the protestors
because the military's job is
to defend the constitution,
not to defend the
judicial autocracy
and takeover of the country
and the shredding
of the Constitution.
And there's a little standoff.
The federal police prevail.
They put the
protestors in buses.
It started off with
400, then it was 1200.
The last number I heard
was that they captured
about 1700 people
and they bring them
to the federal police
training facility in Brasilia,
stick 'em in the gymnasium.
No food, no water, no bathrooms.
Young kids, no food.
Old women, dehydrated.
Intel says, and it's been
pretty well verified,
that at least one
person's died that day.
I heard two people, now they
say it's up to four or five.
And they basically
create a gulag,
which are being called in
Brazil Lulacs, Lula gulags.
- Yeah.
- A portmanteau.
And now after two days of that,
that was Monday and Tuesday,
they let the women
and children go...
By the way, the
images of old people
sitting in puddles
of their own urine
because there're no bathrooms...
Sweltering conditions,
no food, no water.
They let the older women and
the women and children go
and on the condition,
and we have these floating
around, a denunciation page,
you have to sign it
to be released saying,
"I am a terrorist. I
assaulted democracy."
And this now has them on lists.
They will never get a job again.
And they take all the men
and I guess some of the more
able-bodied younger women,
they're now in the equivalent
of a federal penitentiary.
No due process.
They have not had
access to counsel.
We have videos that have
been leaked that show,
"Just kill us already. You've
basically taken everything."
The despair, the despondency,
and the whole country...
And now, of course,
they're clamping down.
They just shut down, yesterday,
Brazil's version of
Fox News, Jovem Pan.
That was shut down by FIA.
So now there's no
alternative media whatsoever.
They've shut down everybody
on the right social media.
The lists of people
who've been deplatformed
on social media is now
into the tens of thousands.
And they're clamping down.
Now Alexandre de Moraes
has suspended the governor
of the federal district,
a state where
Brasilia is a part of.
Suspended the
governor for 90 days.
He doesn't have the power
to do it, but he did it
saying that, "Well, you
did not help us defend it."
I went on Tucker and
said that a senator,
who's not a Bolsonaro
party member at all,
found documents... There
were documents submitted
by security agencies to Flávio
Dino, the Justice Minister,
and Lula saying that there was
going to be unrest on Sunday,
"We should cordon
off the building
so that it's not, you
know, an insurrection."
(Dave laughs)
I mean, it kind of reminds
you of Nancy Pelosi,
who the Capitol Hill
police report to.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I mean, right?
Tucker said it as well, you
know, it's a template now.
- So all these pieces, I think
people are following along,
even if they're missing
some of the specifics
that you're talking about.
The big pieces here
all feel very familiar
to a lot of things that have
been happening across the West.
And even the way
our mainstream media
was ignoring everything
for months then finally,
the events of basically
the last week happen,
and they can start just claiming
that it's a bunch
of insurrectionists
and this is MAGA exported
and the rest of it
and that's what we're seeing
out of all of our
Democrat politicians,
the ones who are
speaking about it
and out of our media
machinery. So to somewhat-
- [Matthew] I'm reading-
- Yeah.
- I'm reading that...
You know, I read in
Vanity Fair and Politico
and Washington Post that, you
know, this was coordinated.
Tucker alluded to this.
Now the media's
covering this, right?
The revolution wouldn't be
televised for eight weeks.
- Right. When they
got what they...
When they got the
images they wanted...
- Then all of a sudden I'm
getting asked for comment
and all of a sudden I'm reading,
"I organized it because
I was covering it."
Or Bannon, 'cause I've been
doing War Room every day on it.
Bannon understands
global communism,
so we've been covering this
for even months leading in
that Brazil's been the most
important electoral battleground
in 2022 against
global communism,
against China coming
into Latin America
and creating the
Orwellian Superstate.
If you read 1984, Oceania,
Eastasia, that's Lula's goal.
He wants a South
American superstate.
He's already floated
one currency.
- We were always at war.
- Exactly, they were always
at war until they're not
and then history gets revised.
They want one currency,
which if you thought the Euro
was a bad idea with
Southern Italy and Spain,
with Germany and
Amsterdam, Netherlands,
two different types of economies
merging into one currency,
all the problems that's created,
how do you have Venezuela, an
absolute communist rat hole
that's been created out
of the Forum Sao Paolo
and Brazil, one of the
wealthiest nations in the world.
Third largest economy
in our hemisphere,
second largest country.
Third after U.S., Canada.
220 million people.
Wealthy in oil, gas, magnesium,
manganese, bauxite, tin,
copper, gold.
Third or fourth largest
food producer to the world.
Wheat, barley, oats.
You know, this is a big
deal that China's gonna have
a very controlled foothold.
And by the way, also important,
I don't believe Lula's the
president of the country.
I mean he is in name;
he's a figurehead.
They let him out of prison so
they could have a figurehead,
they can have somebody
that they could spin.
The people were with him.
It's Alexandre Moraes.
It has been wholesale taken over
by the head of the
judicial autocracy,
the Supreme Court judge
and Electoral Court judge
who has taken all these powers
and has weaponized them
against political opposition.
You know what
they're saying now?
They're saying they
are not going to seat
the right-wing legislators
in the legislature.
This is... I mean, this is-
- Right, they're just
not gonna put them on?
- Because they're terrorists.
- Yeah.
- Because now after
January 8th, you know,
some of these...
Nikolas Ferreira is
a young congressman
who got more votes
than anybody else
in any of the ballots
in Brazilian history
and they are not
going to seat him
because he tweeted
that, you know,
the election's fraudulent,
that Moraes is out of control.
You got Carla
Zambelli, Bia Kicis,
like hardcore
political righties,
are not only gonna
be not seated,
many of them are gonna be
put in jail very, very soon.
So this has gone from zero
to Stalin in record time.
I thought it'd be Venezuela
in six to 12 months.
Well, it's going
to be, you know,
the post-Bolshevik
order in Russia 1920/21
when the first Soviet
government was formed.
It is going to be that.
Show trials, purges, probably
gulags and mass executions.
That's what these
people are capable of.
- Okay. In the
remaining moments...
Again, there's
just so much here.
You're giving us a lot
and we'll do this again.
I want people to pay
attention to this
because even when I...
I think I retweeted one
or two of the videos
that you had posted,
and the amount of people
that I saw responses
from saying,
"We're in Brazil,
everyone's ignoring us.
We're not terrorists. We're..."
I mean, all the stuff...
It's just like they're
being ignored or manipul...
You know, what people
are saying about them
is a complete
manipulation of the truth.
So at the moment, I think
Bolnosaro's here in Florida.
People have taken videos-
- [Matthew] Bolsonaro, yeah.
- Bolsonaro. People
have taken videos of him
basically wandering
around Publix
and seeing what's
going on over here.
So did he technically flee?
I mean, was that a midnight job?
- So, he did not want to be...
You know, he failed in
his attempt to fight back
with the fraudulent election.
The judiciary got to, I
guess, some of the judges,
threatened to arrest
some of the...
I'm sorry, the judiciary
got to some of the generals,
threatened to arrest them,
have still threatened
to arrest them now
if they don't go and weaponize
their forces against
the protestors.
He was not able to get
Article 142 invoked,
so on the 30th...
And you know, if
you're a head of state,
the American sort of
visa program is you
can come in and out
as you please.
So he had to leave
before his term was up
on midnight the 31st
and Lula was sworn in.
But he also...
I know him personally, he
didn't wanna be a part...
The sort of changing of the
guard has a symbolic optic
where you hand the sash
over, you present the sash.
He didn't wanna be a part of
that. He knows what this is.
So between that,
the symbolic optics
and having to get out
because the second...
If he was there, they would've
arrested him that day.
They would've put
him in jail that day.
And now they're gonna
try and extradite him.
He has telegraphed that
he will go back to Brazil.
He may go into exile
in Italy, for instance.
His family has an
Italian background
and I think the
Maloney government
would give him refuge.
I suggested to them,
"Go to Hungary.
They'll give a lot
of people refuge."
But he's gonna go back now,
I believe, in short order.
But it's not gonna
end well for him.
And he said this to Jason and
myself when we met with him,
"This is gonna end one of
three ways: in my arrest,
my death or my victory
and prevailing."
And it doesn't look like
victory and prevailing
is going to happen, so...
Now, he did go to Florida,
which I thought was...
Personally, I
would've gone to Italy
and put in a caretaker
government by force,
but hey, I'm not a
Brazilian politician, so...
- (laughs) Not yet, anyway.
- I mean, he said he
did not want to have
his fingerprints on civil war.
My argument on that...
And I know that, you know,
Vanity Fair and Politico,
they'll have a
field day with this,
is civil war, you have
an option of winning
and he probably would've won
because the military by
and large was with you.
170 of the highest ranking
officers in an unprecedented act
signed an open letter to
Bolsonaro publicized in media,
"We need you to act
and invoke Article 142,
otherwise we are going
to be Venezuela."
Well, he didn't and now it
is Venezuela, but even more.
It took Chavez a few years
to really cement power.
He got power,
democratically elected.
Coercively so, but
It wasn't until he held a sham
referendum to cement power,
I think it was in 2002,
that it got really brutal
and oppressive and they
went after dissidents
and really took just unilateral
control of the country.
This is happening in
Brazil within a week.
- So in essence, he's in exile.
We'll see where he ends up.
Lulu is the, I suppose,
titular head of state,
but you're saying he's
not even really in charge.
We'll see what happens
to all of the quote
unquote insurrectionists.
The media will lie about
pretty much everything.
- [Matthew] Yep.
- Well, I guess in summation,
where should people
go to find out more?
More of something
approximate to honesty
related to all of this
because if you turn on
CNN for the little bit,
or you know, the one
article that might be
on the second page
over at CNN.com,
it's basically, as I said,
it's the MAGA insurrectionists
trying to destroy democracy,
just like they did in America.
- Well, one of the powerful
things of Brazilian populism
is that Brazil is, I think,
and I'd love to see
quantitative metrics on this,
the most social
media engaged country
and citizenry in the world.
Everybody's on social
media and they're active,
they're engaged, they use
technology very effectively.
There is no shortage
of prima facie evidence
from the ground of
what has transpired
and what's continuing
to transpire.
Obviously, I'm a hub
and spoke for it.
I've become a bit of an
English language voice
in global western press,
especially in the U.S. for them.
So my Twitter, my
GETTR, my Instagram
obviously have blown up on this.
I feel like I better
learn Portuguese,
(Dave laughs)
otherwise I won't be able
to use my own newsfeed.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- So it's very,
very social media engaged.
Up until a few days ago,
you did have a sort
of alternative media
and right-wingers,
but they've literally been
shut down by FIA, Jovem Pan.
The right-wingers, the
journalists and conservatives
who are in this country
are all now gonna be pushed
to be extradited back
and be put in prison.
Paulo Figueiredo,
Rodrigo Constantino,
Ricardo Martins who's a pastor,
they wanna put him in jail.
I'm getting messages,
they're so heartbreaking,
the despondency from the people.
I have people who've been
sources for me now for months
and especially in the
last couple months saying,
"I'm shutting down all my social
media to remove the tracks
so that they don't break down
my door at 5:00 AM tomorrow
and put a paper bag or
a cloth bag over my head
and rendition me."
And, you know, my father was
an anti-communist
dissident in Poland
imprisoned by the
Soviets in Lithuania,
dealing with the Poles,
censored and harassed nonstop
for being a dissonant.
So I know, you know,
what this looks like,
and it basically looks like a
Kafka story where, you know,
you get a bag over
your head at 5:00 AM
and then your wife goes to
the police station, says,
"My husband was taken
by the government."
They go, "Oh no, you
just misplaced him.
We don't know what
you're talking about."
- Man, there is a lot here.
I appreciate you packing in a
lot in a short amount of time.
We'll link to your social
media accounts below-
- [Matthew] Thank you.
- ... so people can follow you
more specifically on
the day-to-day stuff,
what's going on here.
But keep it up man
and maybe we'll bump into
him someday at Publix.
You know what I mean? Maybe...
- I don't know.
I think he's probably
not gonna have
that free wheeling a lifestyle
going forward. (chuckles)
- Thank you, Matthew.
- [Matthew] Thank you, David.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.